voici la cible numéro un de la
bronchiolite les enfants de moins de 2
ans et demi sont à surveiller pour
éviter l'épidémie qui a débutée début
octobre des symptômes doivent attirer
l'attention des parents avant que la
maladie respiratoire ne s'aggrave
c'est un enfant qui va énormément tout
si vous rend même s'il est très atteint
par ce virus j'insiste sur le mot virus
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'antibiotiques a
donné en cas de bronchiolite cet enfant
va même sifflé on va entendre des petit
sifflement il faut l'amener très vite
chez le médecin ou à la haye mais fait
mieux enfin il faut qu'ils voient un
docteur
le médecin pourra alors prescrire des
aérosols ou de la kiné respiratoire le
meilleur traitement c'est d'éviter la
maladie
pour ce faire il faut avoir une hygiène
irréprochable et éviter les lieux
publics mais pas les amener dans des
centres commerciaux en périodes comme ça
épidémique ou la contagiosité est forte
et puis ne pas échanger les biberons
voilà le lavage des mains est aussi se
couvrir le nez
et la bouche quand on est malade
l'épidémie ne fait que commencer
elle devrait durer jusqu'au mois de
janvier ou février selon santé publique
france